Humber's Seligmann I'm the co-founder
and chief scientific officer of bio
spider technology I'm going to be
talking about spatial transcriptomic now
that is a new technology new methodology
with several platforms either just
recently commercially available or in
development but I think spatial
transcriptomics means different things
to different people and so I'm going to
write to address some of those
differences as well as some of the
considerations in selecting a platform
to pursue so one of the aspects of
spatial profiling in general is that you
know it's particularly important in that
people can use fixed issue and you don't
have to be a pathologist or molecular
biologist in many cases to carry out
assays in which you can profile cells
glands or histologic structures of
interest within the context of their
micro environment and that's what's
meant by this term spatial
transcriptomics or as I would be talking
about it as spatial profiling most of
the time and one psychometric that I'll
talk about is the one that we've
developed which is called tempo seek so
that's in development at this point it's
not a launched commercial a say but it's
a gene expression assay that can use six
tissue as the sample type it doesn't
again require expertise in electro
biology and when attractive aspect of it
is that the data analysis is largely
automated so it also doesn't require the
support of about informatics expert as
well and this is carried out through
packages called tempo seeker are but the
point about this technology the focus of
it is to enable investigators to get
spatial expression data from their
samples from fixed tissue that's
directly stained either with a change
staining or with antibody staining so
what are some of the factors that go
into making the decision of whether
spatial profiling is
necessary for someone's project and what
are considerations in terms of picking a
platform to carry that study out and the
first is well what's to be gained with
spatial profiling versus profiling a
bulk heterogeneous area of tissue and I
will address that second is what is the
resolution are you interested in going
all the way down to a single cell or
subcellular areas or is the interest to
look at normal glands versus let's say
cancer glands or any type of gland
without getting cross-contaminated
profiles from surrounding stromal tissue
so that's an certainly a very important
aspect in terms of picking a methodology
and also ultimately the cost and
throughput and is there a need for
histologic specificity so among other
things then is to gain as histologic
specificity where you're only going to
profile one specific histology without
cross contamination is that methodology
does it require you to use a reference
section that stained and then the sample
is actually taken off of a second
unstained
section or can the section that you're
actually working from and profiling can
that be directly stained or not
and that brings them to the fore is the
type of sample can you use six tissue or
do you have to use fresh frozen tissue
because that dictates obviously what
types of samples and how many samples
and how a complicated processing those
samples can be and what is the method of
sequencing or of readout is it a three
prime biased method is it targeted and
then in context of that what is it that
you want to measure you want to measure
just what genes are expressed do you
want to measure splice variants or
Express snips or fusion genes or other
mutations you want to measure small
non-coding RNA or long non-coding RNA as
well all those are questions in fact
even if you want to measure histones
which are not probably donated then the
point is whether you would like a free
prime biased method or a different
method
and the other another question is then
ultimately what is the performance was
the gene expression measurement posts a
sensitivity and the spatial resolution
that can be achieved can classrooms a
lot deliver the spatial resolution that
you need to measure the area that you're
interested in and can it do so with
sufficient sensitivity and specificity
and then finding the course is the cost
and the throughput if you're only going
to look at a few sections then maybe
that's not quite as important but if
you're certainly are going to look at
lots of sections from different patients
and in lots of areas within those
sections and both cost and throughput
are really critical questions to ask
so address the first issue well as a
heterogeneous sample good enough this
just shows a section of prostate tissue
that's actually used for TMA's which is
what those circles are leftover from and
you know standard RNA seek message take
a fair amount of material the standard
tempo seek method takes one millimeter
squared or less which is shown by the
green box so what's in that one
millimeter area so this is a blow-up and
you can see it's still very complex has
a lot of different glands some of which
would be normal some which completely
cap cancer epithelium surrounded by
stroma cells in that mix and of course
then there might be also inflammatory
cells as well in there when you get down
to the single cell level so nonetheless
you can get a lot of useful information
off of a you know a bulk tissue so this
shows a study that we carried out using
colorectal cancer where we've looked at
cancer and adjacent normal using 1 to 2
millimeter squared areas of tissue
and if you do that you can see from the
methodology viewpoint if you look at
normal tissue between different patients
each patient is color coded the normal
tissue is in the square boxes over on
the left they're all fairly tightly
grouped which shows what is the
repeatability between patients of the
acid is one assumes a normal tissue
should be about the same between its and
nzu patients whereas on the right you
see the cancer profiles and there is
clustering and so one of the questions
is well we know that for colorectal
cancer there is 700 gene brushing
similar game signature described that's
used to subgroup patients into
clinically relevant subgroups and so if
one looks at this data without adjusting
it and just uses that microarray
signature it turns out that you can take
the cancer tissue off from the template
data and you can assign it to either the
CMS subgroups or the Chris CR is
subgroups and we have one patient that
we could not assign in one patient that
we could only assign to CMS but there is
no adjustment made or differences
between the template platform algorithms
that you might want to optimize to a
versus the microarray so
you definitely can get very useful
information off of bulk samples but if
you go back to the Prostate example and
look at that tissue section
and you have a two millimeter squared
area and then you go down even smaller
than that into it's 540 micron squared
area you see here you have a gland
surrounded by stroma so that and so the
blue arrows indicate where the gland is
the orange is the stroma you have other
glands there and so would you be able to
get the information need if you had
let's say on the 30 micron diameter area
which is circled here in red
just looking at the gland without any
stroma cross-contamination so that's the
type of question to ask and in this
particular method with the tempo seek
actually is a visual mark of where you
profile from and so you can see that
there's no contamination of the
surrounding stroma with that gland so
one can go on and look at a lot of
different types of tissues just to get
an appreciation of what one is talking
about is a single gland good enough or
do you need to go down to single-cell
resolution and so this is looking at
gastric pits and you can see if there's
a blow-up on the right so you can see if
I want if you want to look just at the
gland you can use a series of areas that
you profile and pull together which is
shown on the left but if you want to get
to a single cell now you're down to a 10
by 30 micron area that one would work to
profile so the methodology has to be
able to achieve that to go to single
cell whereas 30 micron diameter multiple
pickings certainly would work fine if
you want to look at the whole grump
gland you can go on to other tissues
this is lymph node starting really at
the more gross scale the marker here is
4,000 microns in lymph node
if you want to look at cervical
epithelium glands or other types of
tissues your down then down to 200
micron type resolutions for a single
gland within that type of tissue so your
you need to be a little bit more precise
but you're not at the single cell level
about memory ducts and other types of
bronchiole and other types of glands
you're at that 100 micron to 200 micron
level of needing that to have that type
of spatial resolution primary oocytes
and now you're down to the 70 50 micron
level and this is this the gastric pits
is what I started off with in this
little series of slides so really it
depends on what the tissue is that
you're looking at and what the questions
that you are asking is as to what
methodology to look toward to provide
that but another consideration is
whether you can use directly stained
tissue or have to use the reference
sample on the left is directly stained
and prostate means that you can manually
go in pick the area that you want and
profile it whereas if you're using a
reference section and that would be the
left sample and you're getting the
sample off the right sample which is a
second serial section you now have to
have fairly complex image analysis
software built into the system so they
can register the reference sample
appropriately so you hit the right area
on the sample that you're pulling your
sample from for profiling and this slide
via I see that the animations messed up
a little bit so we'll rapidly go through
there the point is that for instance if
you were going to look at a gland it may
be fairly large gland it's surrounded by
stroma if you look in the lower right
corner that means your registration
however has been good enough that that
edge of the area that you're profiling
doesn't overlap into the stroma so the
spatial resolution has been much higher
than the area that you may want to be
profiling
and it's going to be down at the 10 to 5
micron area and the problem with that
and using a reference sample is that
that gland in a 5 micron or a 10 micron
section is going to move its edges in
the next serial section is not going to
be identical it's not perfect round or
perfect cylinder it's you know it's
contorted and so there's no guarantee
that that that gland will look like that
in the next serial section and so those
edges just are going to change and you
can get cross contamination then if
you're using a reference sample down at
this level of 100 microns or under 3
microns or less it becomes much more
difficult to use a reference sample so I
wanted to cover a couple of the
technologies and so what I've done here
is gone to publications so I can talk
specifically about that publication and
so this is a spatial transcriptomics
which was really the first of the
methods out there and it's a method
where you basically print an array on a
slide of capture molecule put frozen
tissue down on top of that release the
RNA it's captured and then your profiles
so it's a grid and in this publication
each spots of the grid was 100 microns
in diameter and then there on Center is
200 microns it's my understanding that
they're going to resolutions down to 50
microns as dishes now being developed
more more completely and it uses a
reference section which is shown here on
the left which is stained and then can
be profiled by the pathologist as to
what the areas are and then that is then
correlated then to the grid of profiles
that one gets off esa it's a 3-prime
biased method is carried out in this
publication using fresh frozen tissue
and there was 10 microns thick of
melanoma lymph node note about thickness
so if you're at 10 microns that's
actually your limit of resolution
because you always have depths as well
so if you are trying to get less than 10
microns and you have to cut thinner
sections as well because you have to
look at think of this in 3d not just in
terms of the surface area so again if
you're going down to single-cell
resolution you have to get to think
about the thickness of the sample as
well so spatial transcriptomics approach
is a grid and as you can see in this
image of the hundred micron it's
heterogeneous it's not histologically
specific because the grid doesn't
necessarily line up with small focal
histology it certainly can cover a
larger focal histology well and that's
what's shown any annotation up above is
fairly large areas of lymph node
histology the second method which is the
tempo C method it's being developed
can use directly stains H&E or antibody
stained tissue and I've already shown
the fact that you can profile from a
single gland but if that gland happens
to be elongated then one can take
smaller areas but pull them all together
to cover us glands which are elongated
rather than circular and this uses the
tempo seek method which is unbiased but
it's a targeted sequencing method to it
measured specifically what you have in
that assay in terms of sequences but it
can measure exon junctions splice
variants in other words in kamesha gene
fusions snips and other sorts of
molecules that are not probably identity
so and then the last method is the geo
makes digital spatial profiling pet nana
string has launched recently and so this
is a publication that that has just come
out and when it comes to gene expression
the spatial resolution is 300 microns
and so even though the instrument can go
down lower than that in terms of spatial
resolution in terms of to get data
because of the sensitivity assay that's
useful you need a very large area to do
that in this case they were measuring 88
genes tiling across them so we're
looking at multiple sequences for each
gene 770 sequences using the encounter
is a 928 for sequencing uh in this case
you can directly stain using RNA scope
to look at RNA levels and then pick
those areas and you can do protein but
that would be in a cereal section not
the same section
and finally bicycle which is a single
molecule fluorescence in situ sequencing
is a method where you can look at
subcellular gene expression and so this
is insight you
sequencing so it is slower than the
other methods in terms of having to
actually sequence the image rather
collecting sample from the from these
tissue and then sequencing offline and
right now this method is providing about
200 reads per cell I believe they're
working to get this up throughout 8,000
reads per cell so it looks at a few
genes but it's not restricted into what
gene so you can look at an genes but
it's a smaller number because they're
the depths of reads that one can get out
of the system so basically then you know
the method whether it's free client
based or targeted is important and if it
is targeted can it measure the whole
transcriptome or not is important to
know as well
so I wanted to talk a little bit about
the temple seek assay platform and so
this is a methodology which can be used
of you know fak sorted cells can look at
single cells instead of type
preparations or fixed tissue and it has
single cell sensitivity and so i want to
talk about this because one of the
question is is the method one's looking
at have true single cell sensitivity
obvious Issac does but and how does one
go about assessing that and as I said
before it can use fixed tissue that say
can be stained and it can even use
simple lysate from that sample or an
insight you protocol but either way
there's no extraction of RNA or reverse
transcription required so it's a very
robust simple method and it has the
automated analysis so this stuff shows a
question to ask when looking at a
technology or an experiment to do which
is to ask if you I have a bulk cell
sample and I compare that to a single
cell from that bulk so how does that
correlation look in this case you see
that the bulk cells correlate very
highly to the single cell by by a
fluorescence activated cell sorting and
you can see low expressed genes at the
single cell level that are in the bulk
sample as well so you can basically see
every gene but there is stochastic
expression some genes are not expressed
at the instance that these cells were
fixed for assay and it's later those
genes may be expressed and other genes
may be off you can take the situs pin
and ask them whether the local method
the folks facial profiling method also
has single cell sensitivity and so this
is taking a single cell using a 30
micron diameter aspirant of that single
cell and you can see that it gives the
same single cell results as being able
to see low expressed genes that you can
see from the bulk sample so this is a
test that you can do with any message
out there to ask
what is its performance and am i limits
to only looking at moderate to high
express genes or can I measure every
gene that's from vegetable from bulk
this happened to be mcf-7 cells and then
it goes true then single cell
sensitivity
the other question to ask is you know
what is the repeatability between single
cells and so this is again looking at
the facts assic it's easy nobody in
Psych USA looking at two single cells
and again you see stochastic expression
but you see very good correlation
between those two single cells
quantitatively so this is not looking at
differential expression this is looking
at counts so it's direct number of
molecules in each single cell being
counted this is looking at a whole
transcriptome twenty thousand genes and
using a depth of reads of about five
hundred thousand counts per sample but
that's something you can dial in so this
stochastic expression which is circled
in red here can be caused by the two
method itself would be a technical issue
and can also be biological inherent in
gene expression from single cells and so
there's a component of both and that's
what something the one needs to be aware
of is or is that stochastic need your
low expression we're not measuring every
gene that's measurable or should be
measurable from those cells so I wanted
to sort of move very quickly and sort of
towards the end here - well what is
utility of spacial profiling and so this
table I think is a good presentation
summary of what we have subservience and
that's namely that if you take in an
area and you scrape it you look at the
column that you're on the left in each
case that's called scrape those are the
levels of gene expression from that
scrape tissue that contains a primarily
cancer epithelium but also normal
epithelium and stroma and and immune
cells as well and then if you go in and
you do spatial profiling using the same
sort of resolution as before hundred
thirty micron diameter areas you see in
this cancer - top genes here on the left
upper left are expressed in cancer a
subset are expressed in pen
pin is a precancerous histology but none
of these are expressed in normal wires
with the bulk to you they're all there
so you get a biomarker specificity as a
result of spatial profiling and you can
go through to look at the pin and normal
and so how you have a set of genes are
expressed in normal not in cancer and in
a subset or in pin it you can adhesion
molecules are expressed in all three
stromal markers however are not
expressed in any of them showing that
you do have no cross-contamination from
stroma housekeepers other types of genes
on the upper right are expressed in all
three as you would expect but noteworthy
is and the lower right is immune markers
and cytokines are only expressed in
cancer and only in a subset of those
expressed in pin nothing in a normal
tissue
so
basically then with using the focal
analysis identifies that you can
identify what are histologically
specific sets of genes and this has led
us to hypothesize that the tissue micro
environment exerts phenotypic
specificity that's lost outside of the
tissues setting that means if you
dissociate them you won't see that so
you have to look within the context of
tissue and it could be the neighboring
cells including you this it could be
factors extracellular factors exerting
the specificity but if so then
histologic specific spatial resolution
is going to provide a biomarker
specificity they've never seen in
heterogeneous tissue assays and it may
be possible then to obtain insights into
the mechanism of disease and its
progression and to identify novel
therapeutic targets which are not
possible to identify using heterogeneous
block FFPE samples and it also may be
from this increased biomarker
specificity able to get clear
stratification of patients using focal
profiling rather than heterogeneous
bulk tissue therefore better prognosis
better diagnosis of disease so basically
those are things which we can talk about
generally but there is another aspect in
tempo seek is that more recently people
have been using that to do high-quality
dose response data and so that means
using focal profiling is possible the
one could get I call the dose response
expression studies carried out at the
level of the spatial profiling to
understand how target histology within a
tissue is affected by a compound or drug
just not only for translational studies
but also determine drug efficacy and
side effects for drug discovery as well
so whatever you can do with a bulk you
potentially can do at the level of
spatial profiling so of course we have
the questions can be validate the
hypothesis and is it true beyond cancer
so temple see there's their number of
publications what I would like to sort
of draw your attention to are the two at
the bottom the fixed tissue assay has
been published not the spatial profiling
assay but the bulk assay but in
particular as well they used to provide
dose response data and complex analysis
across the whole transcriptome or across
a set of two thousand or more genes has
also just recently been published and I
think does represent a whole new avenue
of Investigation and opportunity both
within bulk samples and featural studies
and then at the spatial resolution level
as well
so I would like to thank you for
listening to the presentation and I'd
particularly like to thank the people
who contributed to the tempest week data
from bio spider and also consulting
pathologist Raymond Nagel
thank you
you